merci dominique nous ne quittons pas la
ville de dijon pour capter une autre
image du procès elle est signée helmut
newton le maître de la photo de mode et
de la photo de star s'est plongé
délibérément dans l'univers de la sphère
grégory ces photos sont publiées cette
semaine dans paris match
reportage isabelle staes didier deshamps
ça c'est l'univers d'helmut newton
calme luxe et volupté dans l'atmosphère
très intimiste des studios photos
ça c'est l'inédit à 73 ans il se jette
pour la première fois dans l'arène des
paparazzi quand j'ai des garçons à
l'école j'ai rêvé à faire ça sur mais
j'ai jamais fait parce que je suis pas
assez rapide
quand il y avait la bousculade j'étais
pas très efficace c'était très
découragés après l'es2 deuxième jour
parce que j'étais sûr double sûr que
j'aligne est soulevée dépasser le grand
newton pas tant que ça malgré ses envies
d'abandon il a tenu bon
voici le travail la phase 1 qui m'a
vraiment fun
fasciné c'était muriel et je veux dire
lavez votre tête mademoiselle je puisse
thouars groupe aux yeux je crois il ya
quelque chose qui fait un peu animal
c'est un visage d'un autre époque
christine vinh bassam échapper
totalement d'abord je me trompe et comme
vous savez comme tout le monde c'est à
mon chagrin photographie quelqu'un
d'autre à taïwan chine
moi j'ai cette image qui le dos la tête
baissée
ça c'est christine petit à côté de son
avocat il avait des veneurs foule des
spectateurs qui voudraient voir du son
c'est comme une ride
ça fait partie de ce sentiment que j'ai
eu le moyen âge de la une france
profonde de kobo est venue la deuxième
nuit pour le visiter dans ma chambre de
l'hôtel il a frappé à la fête à la j'ai
vite pris mon appareil
il fait son portrait que pas duré très
longtemps était comme les autres traits
fugitifs ont dix fugitifs